for more on the illegal immigrant Mass
shooter captured tonight in Texas we go
to Fox News contributors Leo 2.0 Terrell
and Tommy lahren also former acting ice
director Tom Holman is with us Tom let
me start with you this is your
wheelhouse
um if you wanted to close the border
secure the Border we know how to do it
obviously Joe Biden chose a different
policy what really scared me is the days
went on here and five innocent people
killed including an eight-year-old is
that this guy probably went back to
Mexico but what should shock the
conscience of every American is this guy
was able to be deported and come back
not once not twice not three times not
four times but five times now that only
happens if you have wide open borders
yeah you're absolutely right and this
would not happen on a trump
Administration but you know this guy was
a fugitive right he he entered the
country in weekly after being deported
five times which means five felonies he
also has several DUI convictions under
the Trump Administration being a
fugitive being re-entered felon and
being a DUI condition he would have been
priority I just would have been looking
for him or arresting him and putting
them in prison for a violation of of the
re-entry activism however under by
Administration my Orchestra
I know I just love the lawsuit of Texas
where he basically took him 85 percent
of the criminals that the Trump
Administration rested and deported
so this Administration took him off the
table 85 of criminals ice record and
Trump Administration they can no longer
rest that's what's terrible these five
people that were murdered five innocent
people didn't have to die now that he
murdered five people now he's a nice
priority too little too late but a shout
out to the vortex unit the same abortion
Tactical Unit that took the shooter out
in Uvalde Elementary School they were
involved with this takedown today so God
bless the men and women of border patrol
the same border patrol this President
and this secretary slandered from White
House Podium once again they proved
Heroes of the day so God bless the men
and women in green great well said very
well said uh let me bring in Leo 2.0
Terrell who is also an attorney uh
correct me Leo if I'm wrong but uh Joe
Biden as president took an oath to
uphold the Constitution that means to
uphold the laws of this country whose
Foundation is that Constitution now tell
me if I'm wrong I'm wrong long and my
analysis that not only did Joe Biden not
uphold his oath to office but he was
aiding and abetting in the law breaking
by allowing these people into this
country illegally facilitating it and
offering let's see uh free phones in
some cases free transportation to
whatever state they were going to send
them to uh is and again preferential
treatment because they didn't have to
have a covet test or a covet vaccine in
the middle of a pandemic and don't
forget they dump kids in these cages and
if it weren't for the likes of Senator
Ted Cruz in Texas we would never have
gotten the images of those kids in the
middle of a pandemic in cages that were
overcrowded that Joe Biden built
uh Sean I think you just drafted the
first article of impeachment for Joe
Biden because Joe Biden has failed to do
yeah you have just you have just written
the first article of impeachment because
he should be impeached I mean basically
this Administration has blood on his
hand and as Laura Trump was talking
about a change in leadership if there
was ever a case for Donald Trump to be
president is the southern border we had
a secure border under President Trump
and that's what is missing and I'll tell
you right now besides what's going on he
has basically opened the doors to the
drug cartel sex trafficking the fentanyl
Joe Biden has basically breached and
abandoned his obligation as president in
protecting this country from foreign
enemies Leo I got a question if you were
my attorney and I was arrested uh
because I went down to the border and I
picked somebody up and I drove him to
California or New York or any other
state uh would I be arrested for human
trafficking and likely convicted even if
you the great attorney that you are or
representing me
absolutely and this is what's going on
there's a lot of accessories to the
human trafficking these These are people
in this country who are 80 and abetting
people to get into this country
illegally they would be convicted no
matter how great of a lawyer I may be
I'm going to lose those cases because
that is what's happening right now all
right let me bring in Tommy Lauren Tommy
I know you know for the better part of
your career you're focused uh a lot of
attention on the issue of the border and
illegal immigration uh it was under
control under President Trump you see
what's happening now we're at what
nearly six and a half million illegal
immigrants that we know of that have
come into the country under under Joe
Biden we know how to fix it he doesn't
want to fix it obviously he wants this
policy to continue
they won't recognize what's happening as
a crisis because the Democrats do not
see this as a crisis they see it as an
opportunity it is in fact a crisis but
when they want more voters into this
country they're going to make sure that
they do that by any means possible
they're already planning on giving these
people amnesty at some point and then we
know voting rights is going to come
right along with it so this is all by
Design Democrats play the long game but
let's talk about this illegal immigrant
this fugitive this murderer who executed
his neighbors let's also keep in mind
that in sanctuary cities and states
local law enforcement would not be able
to cooperate with ice so how many people
like this Francisco or a PESA are
existing now in these Sanctuary cities
and these Sanctuary states around the
country these are criminal illegal
aliens that are on the Loose by design
by Democrat policies not just by Joe
Biden but by Gavin Newsom and when you
look at the other cities and states that
have passed similar laws this is by
Design This is a dereliction of Duty
putting Americans In Harm's Way on
purpose and this absolutely should be in
impeachable offense well let me go back
to Leo this became a big deal today it
was in the front page of the New York
Post the New York city mayor Eric Adams
and I thought New York City was supposed
to be a sanctuary City doubled down
accusing the Texas governor Greg Abbott
of targeting quote black Mayors he
doubled down on that accusation about
Abbott with these buses full of migrants
now in total you have about 15 000
illegal immigrants that came to New York
City now the question is if it's a
sanctuary City in a state my question is
I would think that they would have their
arms wide open saying Welcome to our
city but apparently they're calling the
governor of Texas racist or making that
suggestion
offended by this ultimate been race car
he's using the race car to deflect from
his incompetence he is an absolutely
horrific mayor and when he talks about
LA and Chicago where there's other black
mayor why do you think people are
leaving because these are horrible
Democratic Mayors who talk a game of
sanctuary cities but don't want the bird
look at Washington D.C Eric Adams look
at Joe Biden Kamala Harris and that
incompetent White House Press Secretary
who lies all the time about the number
of uh of the reduction in in Immigration
you have to get the those Scoundrels out
of office and put Donald Trump back in
office I want you Tommy I'll give you a
crack at that as well but I mean mayor
Adams is once again you know basically
spreading lies here he knows full well
that these illegal immigrants willingly
chose to come to his City sounds to me
if anybody's racist here it's him
because supposedly he has open arms or
an open border policy but now that they
end up in his City now he's angry that
they hear
the good people of Texas for dinner and
then saying no get the hell out of here
no it's exactly what it is but as I was
saying Sean elections have consequences
the good people of Texas did not vote
for an open border all right but these
people that are in these blue
democrat-run cities and states they
apparently did vote for this so I say we
should enrich their communities bus baby
bus and show them what they voted for if
they're not near the border if they're
not in a border city or state bring the
border to them maybe they'll understand
the danger of course they want to pull
the race card it has nothing to do with
the race of these Mayors it's about the
leadership that knows no skin color look
at the men we have in office he's white
as a snowflake it makes no difference
it's about the leadership you want to
see what the borders doing to American
cities and states you should see it up
close and personal well said hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else